I can see the where it goes yeah it's
creepy more interesting those like if
you if you go to a Korean restaurant and
you're not Korean they do not give you
good service that's true 100% that is
true
like I've literally walked into a
restaurant my friend Vince walked before
me he goes hey can I get they walk past
him and they're like how many tables
would you like pushed him aside yeah
yeah I love that like he was trying that
so I go to Korean restaurant with my
wife friends I do because it's like they
want me finally I have some
responsibility and finally I can hold
court oh it's all right and like be cool
you get mad at you when you don't speak
Korean though come to me you're your
waiter come to me okay I'll go beat you
do this here okay I know that's not
gonna fly what I just said I'm asking
would that fly yes it would all right
god be to get you see a puppet adjust
your kimchi Gahanna just a diet coke how
much you say oh yeah see
or is that all in their mind are they
gonna go this white guy's trying to put
it out Nippon MEP one six people all
right just trick me [ __ ] nut I like how
you just like bailed out at the end
maple is how many right huh that's right
that's all right that's what you said
right yeah try to trick me go ahead with
Korean
[Music]
I am go ahead I'm gonna say gay Saiga
take a uh Salaam Samuel what do you say
there this is [ __ ] no before that
though oh no so how many I said three
you say again take care it's not for
people young so what's a game in tech is
for objects well I said three objects
yeah I'm not with people I was like how
many be nah I'm not with people with the
stool I have a lamp lamp with me and I
have a [ __ ] um ottoman I wonder like
sometimes when I guess for me when we
speak like the broke Korean I I feel
like they look at it like we're the
dumbest people on earth
cuz I would do [ __ ] like that job like
Sega and they're like this person just
had three objects get the [ __ ] out of
here oh yeah you know what I say to them
after that I go yeah I'm a fat Korean
guy on national TV yeah you shut the
[ __ ] up man all right big it's a wet
cave let me see something right now let
me see something right now to everyone
in this room okay
and and I don't you know I'm a humble
person and I love to live in the light
am I not right with the largest week
ever that everybody saw what I'm a
humble person I'm a humble person right
but I'm gonna be honest with you dude
there are times I have low self-esteem
and it gets sad and I get depressed and
I get suicidal at times I do I'm human
about human being who is see with the
[ __ ] okay but what I want to say to you
do I also know what I've done right so
don't you know you're Korean and my
restaurant don't look down on me that
was a good monologue the monologues are
getting better I know they're getting
longer actually felt that dude no I'm
just trying to be real with you dawg you
know I'm being urban Bob it's a plan
raising it did you uh do you always like
cream bars does that give me yes a thing
like cream Barbie yeah I I eat
you man ie all [ __ ] you man you know
what I eat man I'll tell you my the
places I get you know you know this in
two weeks this is where I'll go Connie
and Ted's seafood okay okay I'll go to
arm
what's that cat plays cat a great cat
hungry cat life okay tu my friend huh
okay hungry cat I go to [ __ ] Connie
Ted's I'll go to arm I'll go to arm
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu what's that place
last night I went to jiu-jitsu wait to
see Oh
Fujita they close at 2:00 in the morning
hmm
it's sometimes I'll go to the annex and
sometimes I'll go across the street I
have a third one now yeah they have
right now killer alone oh you go you get
this ooh come in right missiles Conn
again yeah and then I'll go to sometimes
that we don't play it's what's that call
you know what I got today guys and this
is you know you're lucky boy you know in
the books it has the best breakfast
burrito Oh mine yeah lucky boy you just
like the way it's like tightly wrapped
there's a play that's better I feel like
you don't need vegetable country cottage
country cottage in Burbank if you guys
live in LA go to country cottage get
their breakfast burrito [ __ ] rivals
lucky boy I went there today dog not my
lucky boy driving in Pasadena yeah it's
not a driving that's the best breakfast
burrito one of the best beer in LA and
yes I do like really because you train
right by there right yeah it's just
lucky boy driving like I think the thing
I don't like about it is that the cheese
is not melted burrito yeah
like sometimes it comes out cold
sometimes it does it I've never had
melted you've crossed eyes you're one of
those gooks you know one of them gooks
that [ __ ] across why don't you come
train with us who you and what with the
[ __ ] mutant Bart no they do more time
that's some alien wrestling what's up
mutant that you hang out with Bart Kwan
I bet you could I bet you could tap Bart
out yeah you're probably good I bet you
say yellow
thumb yellow joe rogan but yeah he has
wrestled it you were good I was real
good to your brother always talks about
yeah yeah my balance is off the chain
brah I heard you have like a solid five
seconds in the beginning I do miss but
after that five seconds it's a little
yeah yeah I can do I can do a thing
where you're on top of me dude
I'll roll you 100% I believe it I will
roll here I'm frail as [ __ ] okay so I am
tough in that way and I'm strong
I have hrs everyone knows that no I
think it means human [ __ ] strength
exactly you don't think you know and you
get it right I'm like a chimp bro you
step you step at me dude I'll break a
cheekbone with my fingers what do you
think all right I'm getting aggressive
right now dog with you I was agreed you
train all right but I was agreeing with
you I want you to come in here I'm sorry
I want you to teach us
[Music]